[Music]
just to wake everyone up just to make
sure good morning everyone
can i welcome everyone to uh development
control committee a
of mid-south district council can i
first of all just remind you some of the
domestic arrangements for today
please ensure that you maintain social
distance from all other persons in the
chamber and the social areas
please ensure that you wear a mask
unless seated and if you're unable to do
so
and that you use hand sanitizer and
wipes provided
can we please maintain social distance
at all times during the meetings and any
breaks and please ensure your
microphones are muted when you're not
speaking
can i ask that you please don't
interrupt other speakers
members are reminded they should not
have alternative communication lines
open such as
teams chat and if you are contacted by a
third party during any application could
you please bring it to the attention
of our legal advisor if you are
attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
additionally you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by myself
and we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on modern.gov
i'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
internet
and will be capable of repeated viewings
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make any representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes the council members of
the public and press may record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
if we do hear the fire alarm today can
we please leave the building immediately
via the fire exit
make our ways to the assembly point at
ipswich town football club
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exit at each end of the floor
please do not enter the atrium which is
the ground floor area and walkways area
and if you are in the atrium at the time
of the alarm please follow the signs to
the nearest fire exit
please use the stairs and do not use the
lifts
and we should not re-enter the building
too it's safe to do so
so we'll now move on to uh today um so
the
introductions first of all we have just
run through a few people here to help us
today
ian de prez our legal advisor morning in
morning chairman uh philip isbell the
chief planning officer
morning good morning chairman john
payton g
uh over there hi john uh
uh good morning area planning manager uh
claire philpott the government officer
now vincent pierce isn't presenting
john's doing that today harry goodrich
is the case officer and we have robert
carmichael
is there anyone i've missed i hope not
award members for today we have lavinia
hattingham
hi lavinia we have harry richardson
morning harry and then we have written
representations from jessica fleming and
wendy turner but we'll read those out
for the relevant application
so moving straight on to the agenda uh
the first item is apologies for absence
absence and substitutions do we have any
apologies for abstinence please
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor rachel evan
and councilman mellon is substituting
thank you okay adrenal item 2 is to
receive decorations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary by
interest by members do we have any for
today
yeah councilman um i just want to uh
mention that the application 8c in
norton is in my county division not sure
i need to say that or not but anyway
thanks okay um agenda item number three
is declarations of lobbying
oh sorry counselor did you have your
hand up on some on the previous one
yeah it's just i'm not sure it's
necessary but i do know the architect on
one of these
applications ed pure is it i think so he
did some work from the cobbled trust so
they're not saying thank you for that
okay
so just on to the next items decorations
of lobbying
so that's all all the existing committee
members have received and on which
application
all the same yeah good okay thank you
very much
uh decorations of personal site visit by
members are there any
no none received thank you okay so we
now need to confirm the minutes of the
meeting that held on the 3rd of june
uh 2021 um are there any points of
accuracy
in these minutes that anyone wishes to
raise
[Applause]
they're in our papers can i take uh
can i have a proposal that these are
accurate minutes
from obviously someone that was at the
meeting yeah
councilman and a seconder thank you
okay so the governance officer will now
conduct an electronic
vote thank you chair members if you
press the plus sign on the top right of
your modgav app
the vote for this item is now in
progress and it should show in a light
blue colour
so
thank you chair that's six votes four
and two abstentions
thank you um okay the next item is the
minutes of the
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 23rd of june
uh again those have been uh put before
us could i
again have a pr if everyone is happy
with those a proposal
yes casa muller thank you jeff there is
a typo on paragraph 12.1 on page 13.
it should read cedars park community
interest company limited it is the word
company is missing
such as a small typo otherwise i'm happy
to propose thank you okay
thank you for that small amendment can i
have a seconder please
counsellor field thank you okay again um
governor's office will now conduct an
electronic vote thank you chair
one moment
okay that vote is now in progress for
you members
you have to scroll down
would you like me to take yep
thank you members that's uh seven votes
for one abstention chair it's carried
great thank you very much okay next is
to receive notifications petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme are there any received
let me see thank you okay so we move on
to the first planning application before
us today which is dc
20 03457 land and
buildings at red house farm pressing
field and now
invite the case officer for today john
pate mcgee who's going to take us
through that
john over to you
thank you all right bear with me when i
get used to this because i've done this
for a while
all right okay and that one goes up and
down
okay thank you
members so this application is uh landon
buildings at red house farm
uh this is probably a road in fessing
field it's a reserve matters
application so we have layout appearance
scale and landscape they're all before
us today
access is not before us that was part of
the outline
uh consent there are other other matters
within the outline as well that were
covered off and i'll go through those
as we go through the presentation the
proposal is for 28 dwellings
as that's set number not up 2 and that's
what's before us
so this is in wrestling field it's a
primary village um
in the future will be hindu land village
as it states there so this is where we
are
the parish council have objected to this
proposal they're recommending refusal of
the application
uh as the ditch for which the excess
water from the attenuation pond
is sealed at both ends this has been
amended since this objection
and we now have a solution to that that
has been agreed by
suffolk county council so essentially we
found a different way for the water to
flow
put into context here we are at pressing
field it's the the yellow
dot on the top there
and the local context as we get a bit
closer
and the site itself this is the red line
plan
and this it was a hybrid application
originally so it had two
elements to it it had a full application
which was for the scout heart
which would be on which is not on this
plan but to the right
and the outline element was for the
housing
so it to the north we've got new street
for which the
access has been agreed to be part of and
there is also a lane as well we'll come
to in a moment so this is the context of
the
site in respect of the village
and it's on the west side of the village
uh it does sit adjacent to the current
settlement boundary but it is an
allocated site within the neighborhood
plan which i'll come to shortly
this constraints plan shows the
conservation area in the top right
corner obviously some distance away from
this site
and it also shows the scattering of
listed buildings
as well
so flexing field neighbourhood plan
which is adopted
this is one of its key allocated sites
and essentially as states there um
it's looking for 28 houses which is
what's before us
and the application complies with the
requirements of the
neighborhood plan
um what's that
right so i apologize i'm taking over a
presentation from a colleague of mine
the point being raised here is that the
designation of houses within the
pressing field is for around 60
and this is part of that 60
houses for freshing field we have
refused
other applications within thressing
field because
those would exceed the 60
allocated number for the neighborhood
plan
returning to the reserve matters so this
is the layout
um and there has been amendments uh
during the course of the application
now one of those amendments is to vary
the verge
and allow for drainage from the
attenuation basin to flow
to an alternative ditch so the one
originally
looked at wasn't viable and that's why
you have an objection from the
parish council but an alternative has
been
found successfully the scout heart
site is to the bottom of the page there
and that was a full application and
dealt with separately
if i carry on through and of course that
leads to
i'm going to say primary lane but i
forgot the name of the lane i do
apologize
but that is a pedestrian access
eventually that will go through
to that uh lane leading to the center of
the village
and then all traffic will go through the
new
estate road for both scouts eventually
and the housing that's to be built
the estate roads have shown now the um
the orange road has essentially been
approved
via the outline permission so
that has been dealt with um
because it was part of the full but the
all other roads are part of the layout
before you today
all of the roads will be unadopted
although the estate roads will be built
to adoptable standard
for the future
we have bungalows within the scheme
these bungalows have been positioned
along the edge of the development uh
usefully
near to existing development
to ensure no privacy
issues
we also have here the back-to-back
distances
shown as well and of course we are
dealing with bungalow development
in respect of the edges there
this scheme has built brick wall
boundaries
and that's all part of the ethos of the
scheme to have a rural feel
when you come to the actual design of
the properties and they all kind of flow
into the walls so
a lot of thought has been given around
that to ensure
a new sense of place is being created
and looking at the individual house
types we have
real chimneys we have decorative barge
boards
and quite a lot of traditional detailing
and there's a wide range of styles being
proposed
now this is one example where you know
even though it's essentially four houses
in one here
um it's a mason that is designed to look
like a row of
four cottages
and we also have bungalows
we have half hit roofs as well which is
a traditional feature
and this leads us to the front now so
from new street to the north of the site
as you look
it's about the entrance to the site if
you like
this is essentially the street scene
that is being created now this street
scene
is actually set back it's not on the
street you have got the attenuation
basin
set in front of this and the road before
you see
what is you know trying to appear as a
kind of rural farmscape
style in respect of uh weatherboarding
and raw materials
and low level as well before you
obviously go into
the rest of the estate so there's a but
there is a it is quite far set back so
um you know it just sort of doesn't
really affect the street scene
overly
we have traditional materials
throughout the development
so just picking up on the reserve
matters and what is reserve matters and
what isn't
just for clarification and you have the
main estate road the one running from
new street to the top down to where the
scalp hut will be
and existing properties
that is already been approved so the
access and its visibility at the top
there has already been approved
and again just showing what has been
improved already
although we are putting a raised table
within that
to ensure that we don't have people
racing down that road
there are no triple parking
and in terms of the front ish
development there was a concern that you
wouldn't be able to come in and out of
that but we've
we are happy that there is enough space
and setback to allow
turning maneuvering uh to be possible
and necessary
and again just looking at the bungalows
again
and if you were to imagine a standard
fence line it's the shadow
shown on that picture we are satisfied
that given the distances given the level
of land
uh the overlooking and privacy issues
wouldn't be a concern
now turning into the drainage mata which
the parish council have raised
essentially um the attenuation basin
was like a sealed location there was
nowhere for the water to go once it got
there
um and what we now have is
an alternative to ensure that the
drainage
has got an outflow to another ditch to
the southern end
we're also looking at a shallower than
normal
attenuation basin uh just keep making it
appear more softer in the landscape
i think the landscaping otherwise is
fairly uh
self-explanatory so we have then the
reserve matters again
dealing with the scale landscape
appearance
and layout and that is a recommendation
as per your papers
for approval thank you okay
not not a problem but perhaps it's
useful before we start debate just to
touch on
the fact that the government has been
busy in the past 24 hours and issued a
new version of the
national planning policy uh framework so
that was
uh issued yesterday um i i'm not able to
give you a
a blow-by-blow summary of it this
morning hour reading overnight of the
uh changes are that we now have the
notion of beauty included in the concept
of
design so there is an emphasis on that
and reference also to
what some members will be aware of which
is a national model design code
so both of those things are now relevant
the policy applies from publication so
it's relevant to the decisions you take
today
uh and and officers will talk to some of
the issues as we go from our perspective
reviewing this overnight we don't
believe there's anything
anything that substantially changes our
recommendation
and you will see also in the table
papers you have two points that pick up
one on
uh drainage matters and further advice
from the flood
authority and secondly on highway
aspects just for the record and
we can speak to those as need be but
chairman in essence
the nppf uh has uh introduced a concept
of
beauty and sustainability into buildings
we have an outline planning permission
here though and we have to work within
the scope the reserve matters
before us this morning thank you thank
you juice for not bringing you in early
okay so questions yes councilman
councilman
mayor then muller sorry thanks chad um
probably migrants can you talk to me
about um
the adopting of the roads um why they
haven't been adopted is that normal
um it is a choice of the developer
ultimately um
we it does happen we have got
a lot of unadopted roads within the
district uh some quite
significant ones actually but uh
ultimately that is the choice of the
developer
but we are satisfied that the standard
to be reached will be uh satisfactory
counseling uh thank you chair um john
can you please tell me
who will be maintaining the attend the
attenuation pond
please
i'm going to assume there's a private
management company but i will check
um if that's okay i might need to buy a
penis to
which had the um access through the
scout hut
site just i might have missed it but can
you just confirm that there's
a bollard and it's quite close to the
southern end of the road and there isn't
anything at the
hammerhead so vehicles could actually
progress from the hammerhead
to the bollard and then get stuck
and also could you tell me how these
houses are to be heated
in terms of the heating i don't know um
that does not reserve matter before us
in terms of the scout height can you
possibly put the presentation back on
again i can just flick to the right
slide
hopefully this is at the beginning
it's the end
so the one we're talking about
i know the one you want about but i just
that one
so there is you've got the turning head
but you've also got
accesses to a commercial use to the
south as well
so you need to allow
it through that far to allow access to
that commercial use
um but that's all i know
on that but there are businesses at the
bottom there as well
can i just come back on the other matter
uh what was that determined to outline
then
how the houses were to be heated if it's
not a reserved matter to me
it is part of a design of a building so
was it what was what was the
stipulation at outline stage
can i come into this um if you go to
page 96 you'll see the outline planning
permission
at least the conditions attached to it
um
so condition three is a
standard wording condition uh which
relates to the reserve matters
in this instance but would typically
relate to all reserve matters
and that requires the approval of
details uh
of appearance scale uh
layout and landscaping now i understand
what councillor
mansell is describing in relation to her
interest in heating
i don't advise committee that heating is
a reserve matter thank you chairman
thank you yeah can i ask officers first
whether they received my
email of the 18th um posing questions
are relevant at this point um
and if not i will i will just um
outline what it says um that the
drum can i just suggest you ask each
question yeah yeah that's not that's
difficult
for the members of the public benefit
who might be watching it it's all one
question
the question is that for this
application
listed as one of the policies to be
considered
is is cs3 and cs4
which relate to um mitigation and
adaptation
climate change essentially and um
so my question is that the
um the approval the outline approval
included our standard
resource and energy condition but i
can't see anything in
in the papers today in terms of the
design of these buildings
or indeed the heating of these buildings
um
which actually addresses that and so
i wanted to know whether the
environmental management officers
had been consulted and signed it off
already because that isn't in in they're
not listed as console t
um or whether we really actually ought
to be considering the matters that um
councillor mance was beginning to talk
about
um so i apologize firstly for not
getting back to your email um
unfortunately i was on leave yesterday
um in terms of the question there's sort
of
two parts to this um
you've referred to the two policies in
question the first policy is cs3
um so that is policy cs3 reduce
contributions to climate change
so the first part of that policy states
that we will promote and encourage
uh the appropriate development of
standalone renewable energy schemes this
is not a standalone renewable energy
scheme
um and on that basis it doesn't apply to
this application well
it didn't apply to the outline but
doesn't apply to this application either
um
the remainder of that policy talks about
codes for sustainable homes
that was withdrawn by government a few
years ago and on that basis this policy
perhaps should not have been
referenced in respect of this
application and i also understand its
reference in respect to the next
application on your agenda
and you probably shouldn't be referenced
there so on that i apologize for
putting you towards cs3 cs4
is adapting to climate change now that
talks about
all development proposals will
contribute to the delivery of
sustainable development
and reflect the need to plan for climate
change
a point that would be picked up in the
outlying permission the remainder of
that policy
refers to flood risk and sustainable
drainage
which is covered by the proposal before
you
in terms of the attenuation basin and
the subs scheme
proposed there's no flood risk in this
case in terms of being flood
zone two or three so
argue you know in terms of cs3 i
apologize for that policy being included
in terms of cs4 the relevant part of
that
is the flood attenuation basin which is
before you
and is covered by that policy um in
terms
of the condition within the outline the
outline
um and i will say this counts for both
this application and the next one as
well
they both are prior to commencement of
development conditions
and on that basis i can't do anything
until i get those details
from the developer when they so wish to
submit them
prior to the commencement of the
physical development
council oh yes
i thought you were that that leaves that
leaves outstanding essentially the
the related part of my question which
was about the involvement of our
environmental management officers or not
um they have not been well they've been
environmental health have been consulted
but they have not
um we've not specifically consulted the
sustainability
officer on this scheme we do not need to
in this context
we're not in debate now council madison
we're just asking questions
uh yep just just for clarity and i did
send an email around yesterday to all
members drawing attention to a secretary
of state's decision in kent
um i i fully understand the debate that
is happening and
is of considerable interest to members
around carbon reduction and the climate
change and emergency issues
the planning process operates on the
basis of confidence
in the formal documents and the formal
consideration process
and the plan making process in my
opinion is the proper place
to to get ahead with those matters this
decision
as i recall was taken in august 2017 a
slightly different landscape the one we
presently
occupy and we have to work on the
reserve matters
in relation to this application rather
than any other question which we might
prefer to answer thank you
i shall move my chin accordingly uh yeah
thank you very much
um it's just a point of clarification i
know this is a hybrid application
what what is the link and where we're
looking at the reserve matters for for
for the 28 hours what's the link between
this application and the um
and the scout hut very briefly or isn't
there any at all
in terms of ownership or in terms of i'm
not quite sure the context sorry link
in into it there was simply an
application that put both
elements together as one application
originally and i
as and i'm guessing here but i i'm from
communications with
various parties i understand they've
both gone their separate ways to develop
their own piece
accordingly chairman if i yeah
if i can add i think um from my
recollection of 2017 as i was here at
the time
this was something which was of
importance to the community it's
identified
uh uh as being so from the comments at
the time
and i think this was viewed as uh an
opportunity to answer
two questions one in terms of delivering
some homes and in terms of providing
that scatter
it may well be the ward member can put
much more detail on that
thank you councilman thank you chair um
question on visitor parking i think it
was um
slide 32 of the presentation had
some colored dots but i couldn't see if
there was any
visitor parking there um is it just
because of the
the colors very similar to the other dot
or
is there actually any visitor provision
i can't see on the scale i've got so can
i come back to you on that question as
well
i just need to pull up the larger scale
plan um
as well when they come up yeah i would
admit the visitor carping i think is in
the parking court in the in the top is
where the visitor parking is but i
i just need to clarify that thank you
any other questions at all for the
officers no okay
oh sorry i didn't see you there sorry
um thank you um john um i had an email
this morning from the
the parish council saying they haven't
seen the drainage plans
and frankly asking for this to be um
deferred or referred
i mean why would that be why would they
be writing to all the committee to say
they haven't seen the drainage plans
um i don't know but i can check the
consultations in just a moment as well
i'm sorry i'm just trying to look back
into the application to find it
uh for the car parking so if can i keep
going it's the drainage plan on the
website
uh i will check in just a moment i'm
just gonna log on now uh to check
if you could just give me two minutes
and not get on
i think what we'll do is while you're
looking that up we'll proceed and ask
the
uh we'll move on and then we'll come
back to john to answer those questions
okay so
[Applause]
now move on so from public speakers we
don't have a representative of the
parish council here today
or an object or a supporter so i now ask
the agent to come
to the chair and you can do it from
there great so you have three minutes
for the committee
um and we have the timer here so over to
you
thank you very much good morning um
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you today in support of our
application
my name's ed thiel i'm the architect and
the agent for the development
as you just heard from the officer's
reports reserve matters application for
an outline extent approval
the original approval being the hybrid
of this development and the adjacent
scout type which is being developed
separately
this scheme is for 28 new dwellings in
which nine are affordable units and a
further nine are bungalows
the scheme has been developed over the
period of the application before during
pre-application through consultation
with the local planning authority
in response to stakeholders consultation
comments and neighbors
we're therefore confident this is a
scheme that is well developed and
considered being both sensitive to the
site and its wider setting
and a positively look to address the
comments raised during the application
concerns raised over drainage have been
thoroughly considered and have all been
responded to since the comments were
raised
the pond to the front of the site will
enhance biodiversity and provide an
attractive feature
but will also act as an attenuation
basin water from here under flow control
and with the benefit of a pumping
station
will run south through the site and away
to the existing open drainage course
to the south and west of the site
further to this all paving and roadways
are designed to be permeable to further
reduce the impact of rainwater and
surface water on the site
the main estate road which will be built
to adoptable
standards will have additional surface
water attenuation and oversized pipes to
help
with this this has all been developed by
civil engineers gh bullard
meets both local and national guidance
standards for a one in 100 year storm
with a 40
over increase simply put the proposed
works will alleviate the concerns raised
during the course of the application
and ensure that the water from the site
will not impede on or impact upon the
existing drainage of the village
the site has a wide variance of property
types and plot sizes with a mix of one
two and three bed dwellings
with the affordable housing requirements
ensuring that the site will appeal to a
wide range of occupants and
purchases frozen fields an attractive
village
with a well-established local plan and
in response to these factors we've
carefully considered not only the layout
but the materials also
to ensure the development will fit both
the settlement pattern and styling
with local and typical details and
materials selected a range of building
types have also been included to ensure
a varied and interesting feel to the
site
bungalows have been placed to the
adjacent to the existing neighbouring
properties to ensure no impact on
immunity or privacy
and largest dwellings overlook the
fields beyond the site good-sized open
spaces have been created
for added amenity use as well as
creating a sense of open space within
the site and on-site layout
has been carefully considered to avoid
overlooking of new and existing houses
as well as ensuring all plots have
adequate and enhanced private space
around themselves
via outline approval the principle of
development on the site has agreed
frozenfield's neighbourhood plan has
allocated this site with 28 dwellings
and therefore the site and proposal
responds to the identified housing
requirement
not only this but we have developed this
proposal in a thoughtful and sensitive
manner to enhance the village
thank you very much that was spot on
three minutes thank you
okay any questions yes casamayor
thanks cheer um a question regarding the
roads that are built to adoptable
standards
and apparently it's your decision not to
get them adopted can you expand why
you've decided that's the correct route
to take
uh that's a choice that the developer
has made
to which is as as the officer john said
earlier is not an uncommon one amongst
developers
um the the we are building them to the
standards expected with um with all the
absolute the build up and the
the sizing and dimension so it's all
been designed along the
standard set out by suffolk county
council but the developer has made the
decision to
maintain them as private roads
is that purely on costs then i believe
so yes
i'm sure the residents will be delighted
in years to come when they need
resurfacing
okay any other questions yes
casa madison and councillor yeah
further to the questions to the officer
how are these houses going to be heated
the i believe the intention will be that
there
will be the use of air source heat pumps
councilman um could you just um
clarify um whether there are to be any
affordable
bungalows because in your
um in your presentation you
said nine affordable houses and in
addition
nine bungalows i just wondered if there
were any affordable bungalows i'm trying
to look at the paperwork
um one paper says that there are some
and another bit of paper says that
aren't
uh no there aren't any affordable
bungalows i don't believe
the um the quote the um
split of what's of the affordable units
and what is what in terms of bedroom
size
has been um discussed at length for
strategic housing
we did look to include an affordable
bungalow and we're asked to change that
around
so the mix of affordable is
four one bedrooms
two three bedrooms and three two
bedrooms
um ask for some clarification because
i've got the um strategic housing
response up on my screen
and it says proposed homes for
affordable rent and it includes two two
bed bungalows and one three bed bungalow
i am but flats also count don't they
in the context of their response i i
need to um
because you've got the the mason jets
that are also the portables
um i've got the affordables now on
screen if if you just bear with me so i
was in the middle of looking up the
parking and the uh
the other issues um it might be easier
to show
this so plots um
7 8 9 10
are affordable they are two-story
i've got plots 23 which is
i know i need to convert the other plan
bear with me
right so there there the one glows right
if i compare it to the plan i've got
here show me the affordable
we don't have any bungalows before us
so in terms of affordable housing
all the bungalows are market housing
that is the proposal before us
and that's as laid out in our papers on
page 54.
i'm guessing okay uh yeah councilman
yeah i i stopped at the at that same
point and i think
the the um that what i concluded was
that
that was what was originally proposed
and
and as the agent has just said um that
was subsequently changed at the request
of
you know out requests housing department
so i think you know it's all
all okay um actually
thank you any other questions for the
agent at this point yeah counselor thank
you
um i know that um that someone asked
john this earlier but do you know um
about the attenuation basing and the
surrounding area who will um control
that in the future control the water
flowing into the base and the valves and
maintain the whole attenuation basis
yeah as i understand it it will be done
via
a management um committee um or
um company and that um the obviously the
equipment running with the attenuation
will all be um sort of alarmed with um
service agreements in place so if there
are issues it can be dealt with
okay john question some of the answers
some of the questions
all the answers apologize for not having
these um immediately so the parking uh
visitor spaces are within the uh parking
court of um to the north of the site is
it possible just put the presentation up
one more time sorry
just go to the layout um hang on that
one
right uh was that the best one to show
it's not very clear one here at all but
there are a number of spaces within this
section here
um some of those are to serve plots uh
eight to nine sorry eight to ten uh but
equally there are
visitor spaces in there as well and that
complies with the visitor requirement to
the uh
highways uh guidance the other
question was the consultation in respect
of the attenuation basin
uh this shows the drainage
plan was
submitted on the 2nd of june
then consultation with everybody
including the parish council
was carried out on the 3rd of june and
their response was received on the 24th
of june so all of that is public and
the drainage plan is all on there so we
we have consulted them on the drainage
plan
according to our records but if there's
been a mistake somewhere and on the line
i
don't know um does that cover those two
things often
thank you okay any other questions for
the
agent nope okay thank you very much
um next we move on to the ward member
councillor hattingham over to you
thank you good morning members i
supported the outline permission for the
original hybrid application on this site
back in 2016.
my feelings being that this development
was the right side of new street so that
mothers and school children
need not cross or even use the
pavementless main street of the village
on the twice daily walk to school
and i'm also supportive of the scout
movement and was fully aware they needed
a new place to meet
and had been offered space here by the
landowner
happily the site is now part of the
adopted fretting field neighborhood plan
for housing allocation
i did share the parish council's concern
regarding the drainage and jason
skelton's previous holding objection
i was also concerned about highway
issues raised and there are an awful
obstruction of the public right of way
but vincent and the late papers have
quelled all my fears and i'm really
pleased to see a well thought out and
pleasant development
with a nice mix of 10 year in size
including nine bungalows and i'm happy
to commend it
i would like members to ensure removing
permitted development rights excuse me
to create rooms in the attic space or
outdoor windows or other apertures in
the roof of the bungalows
so as not to prejudice the immunity of
the adjoining properties
and upset the neighbors and also to
ensure the connection through to the
priory road will be controlled to
restrict access to emergency vehicles
only
um i am concerned that like i said i
haven't spoken to the parish council
last night i did speak to die last week
and she seemed happy
but to get this email this morning a bit
i don't understand
you know what exactly they have or
haven't seen so i will just put that out
there that like i say
you will receive the email i assume as
well and um
yeah apart from that i'm happy with this
thank you
thank you very much any questions for
the ward member
yes council maths i seem to recall on
earlier pressing field
applications um issues with the sewage
system
um is this this location
i'm not likely to even get involved with
that
i think i'll lecture on
it again i apologize i'm not a case
officer but
vincent did tell me that the the scheme
has been
very mindful of that particular issue
and that is why they
made sure the the issue of sewage is
often to do with the surface water
going into the system uh so this has
been very mindfully put together to make
sure that the
surface water avoids that and that is
why they've had to go through the
alternative route has now
proposed um so they have they've been
very mindful of that and that is
covered
[Music]
okay thank you very much so members it's
now up to us to debate
and discuss this and come to a
conclusion yeah
councillor you want to go first yes
thank you very much chair
um having listened to the ward member
and the other comments made by
other countries etc and read the papers
i'm more than happy
to recommend that we grant planning
permission as stated in the papers
can surpass me okay they're right about
them this time
yeah no i think it's a good application
to listen to the um
questions and discussions i absolutely
agree with the ward member
and then dave murray so i'm very happy
to second approval as per the
recommendation
okay other people yes councilman
um thank you chair i i don't think i'm
quite as happy as the
previous two speakers um
um and it's interesting to hear from um
mr isbell that
beauty is now to be part of the mppf
and to me beauty is in the eye of the
beholder so i'm not quite sure
how we're going to apply such policy
i'm not a fan of things pretending to be
things they're not
um and these are trying to pretend
they're a sort of farmhouse
setting of of cottages which they're not
they're a 21st century housing estate
um i'm also a bit concerned about the
rear parking courts they
are not really flavour of the month
these days and
looking at the location of the parking
and i believe the visitor parking
on that sort of northeastern corner
to be honest my perception of the
general public
maybe it's a bit warped i don't think
anyone's going to use it
because look how far it is to the front
door of the houses
um so i'm not convinced that the layout
is right
i'm pleased that the um agent
said that the houses were to be heated
by a source heat pump
uh because on first sight of this site
of this layout i thought
the roofs aren't really the right
orientation for solar panels but
okay they're not going to be gas heated
that is a plus point but
um i just i just don't think it's the
best layout i i think the rear parking
courts
are could cause problems and i don't
think they're going to be used
i also think that it's disappointing
that they're not going to be adopted
roads but that probably isn't a planning
matter
so i'm i'm sitting on the fence or
should i say brick wall actually
um in this application at the moment
thank you okay thank you
anyone else wish to speak yes that's
from there
i i quite like the development um i too
have an issue with the parking at the
top there it's surrounded by fencing
um there's no natural visibility to
to protect the vehicle's park there and
i'm sure freshenfield don't have any
yobos but they could
could be an attraction for the youth to
gather and
cause damage etcetera so i'm not sure
that's a sensible idea
but in balance i'm happy to support this
game
council matheson sorry thank you yeah
the
i must say i am that the the
this so it looks good uh i agree
um is it is it a 21st century or
or is it gonna need um retro fit in with
with
improvements in a few years time i think
that's that's a problem for the
for the developer and the people that
buy them but what i think we've still
got the possibility of having some
control over
is how the resource and energy condition
on the outline is actually dealt with
the reason we're doing those conditions
at outline stage
is to give the developer an opportunity
to take that into consideration in the
designs that we've brought
forward at the reserved stage which is
where we are
and so it's it's disappointing that that
um
one cannot see and and i fear that the
the agent did only say that he believed
they would be
they would be heat pumps um so really
that's not very reassuring in terms of
dealing with the the imminent current
climate crisis so what i would
ask members whether they would agree is
that we actually
bring back to committee what the
environmental management officer says
when they do see the how
the energy condition is going to be
discharged but apart from that
i'm reasonably comfortable with the
application
cancer field
yes i think i'm reasonably comfortable
with it uh
considering the issue of beauty it is in
the higher the
older as we said i'm certainly
not in favor of things pretending to be
what they're not
but then whenever i see applications for
starkly modern
uh housing development i see colossal
local opposition to that as well so
i'm inclined to think that perhaps a
vast majority of people don't think
exactly the way i do so
i'm happy to support this has been more
likely to be the sort of thing that
local people
require i think i'll leave it there
okay and no one else wishes to speak so
i guess the question for councilman
councillor passmore was we've had a
couple of requests we had one on
permitted development rights from
councillor hadingham
and then we had one from councillor
matheson i don't know how you want to
play those two it's over to you as you
proposed and seconded
yeah there is a mention about the
permitted development uh rights in the
actual recommendation
one particular particular one um
the condition that uh councillor
matheson raised
um if that can be added i've got
personally got no objection to that
so i guess the question is what would
you
want uh so what would you just ask
that i mean yeah i think we've got to be
careful here because that's all quite
contrary to what's in there can we not
i'm not actually in favor of bringing
him back and delaying it to come to a
committee all over again but if the
officers could deal with the
the environmental issues as part of the
recommendation
if it's given approval i would i would
personally think that should ought to be
sufficient
we already have lots of policies don't
we on this anyway
that's my view anyway possibly i can
help
um so this is in regard to the
sustainable energy sustainable statement
condition
um ultimately when a discharge condition
comes forward at this moment in time
it is a delegated matter however
we i can only give you assurance that we
do consult
the environmental health section and
their sustainability officer within that
and he's obviously the expert that we
have in-house to look at that and we
you know there is the possibility that
officers may go against their
recommendation but it is very rare and
we need justification but they
essentially would listen to the advice
expert advice given in the management of
that condition
um i do also take the point that the
condition does say prior to commencement
and members may be aware in the last
year
we have been changing that model
condition so it is
ahead of the game to be concurrent with
reserve matters but we are looking at a
legacy
even though it was a few years ago that
we are dealing with now
and in the future is an evolving process
okay so i think that's covered off as
what you're really saying it will it
happens automatically
yes i'm more than happy with that chair
yeah thank you okay okay so on that
basis
i think we'll go to a vote uh the
recommendations are laid out on page 58
before us
and i now ask the chief planning officer
to read out the proposal that's before
us and then we go to a vote
thank you chairman recommendation before
you on page 58 effectively is uh linked
to the outline
expired condition which relates to the
timing of this the timing is contained
within the
uh outline planning permission second
condition obviously is for
a plans listing condition to ensure that
the approved drawings are what we get
and one of the things that's interesting
about the latest nppf
is that it does specifically include a
paragraph regarding the
subsequent amendment and change to
scheme designs as being
something that can lead to a reduction
in in quality so just for information
that's a point there
materials we've got us the condition the
delivery of the landscaping
is our fourth condition to make sure
that that works effectively and that
ties in
with the drainage condition at condition
7 because you'll see that
the lead flood authority are keen to
ensure that there is
appropriate landscaping around that
fifth condition relates to ev
charging and provisioning you can omit
condition eight because that's a
duplicate of condition seven
edition six removes from the development
rights that uh council hading was
interested in relation to a number of
things
extensions operations alterations and
and new openings to ensure
privacy and amenity and obviously
condition seven relates to the advice of
the lead flood authority in relation to
draenei
thank you chairman um could could i just
um clarify you're removing um number
eight because it's
pretty much similar to number five but
it just says ev provision
uh does that include the ev charging
provision
for the rear parking courts
so so for clarity uh chairman if we if
we can make condition five ev provision
and charging so that we have
thoroughness in in what we're
proposing to you uh councilman no that's
fine same point okay
good so on that basis um we can go to a
vote having been proposed by councilman
secretary council possible
thank you chair members if you go to
your model gov
app the vote is now in progress
thank you chair that's six votes four
and two against that's carried
okay thanks very much now uh because we
have to do a bit of cleaning uh
as we swap people around et cetera for
on this side i as people come into new
seats uh so what we'll just take is a
five minute break just to allow that to
happen in case anyone wants to run
anywhere
um quick five minute break we'll start
again
so welcome back everyone um so we now
move on to the next
uh application which is dc 203098 land
of
land south of disroad bottlesdale uh and
we now hand over to the case of strong
paymentry who's going to take us through
this one
thank you so learn selfish road
buttersdale this is again a reserved
matters application
and also includes discharge conditions
which
we can do so discussion conditions 11
and 12
in this case i'll come to that in a
moment um
outline planning permission was granted
it included
access so the reserve matters before you
is the appearance landscaping layout and
scale
only this is for 69 houses
some open space and i should also point
out
we have increasingly started to do this
and this is probably one of the earlier
applications
that we did do this which is where we in
the outline
application and as we've discovered we
are evolving what needs to be put into
the outline
to get ahead of the game but in the
outline in this case we did agree the
actual market
and affordable housing mix so there were
45
market houses 24 affordable houses
and the mix is as outlined in page 143
of your papers and the mix being the
number of bedrooms sizes all of that is
essentially
agreed up front in the outline on this
occasion
so a little bit more was in the outline
than perhaps you normally would expect
um
the this application also includes uh
conditions 11 and 12. so
conditions 11 12 before us are both in
respect of the sustainable
urban drainage system this is the
attenuation that you'll see on the plans
and the club team from county council
uh support the proposal in that regard
so
more technical reasons to be in here
rather than than separate conditions
like even funds so
here we'll start with the aerial
photographs so the site is
in bottasdale and just
fly through those we're on the edge of
watersdale um
essentially it's one of the entrance
points uh to the
very linear character that bottasdale
and ricky hall have
and you would essentially come on the
main road
and as you looked left as you were
coming into the village you would
see what will be the attenuation basin
location
and then the long access road will go
around into the back of the site so it's
quite an unusual shape
site but it will become more apparent as
we go through
it is an open field um pretty much i can
all i can say there is some mature
landscaping
uh along the edges of the field but
although the site itself is set within
the field uh the constraints map
the special landscape area
is adjacent to the conservation area to
the west
so if i take this the conservation area
point
there and it's open at that point that
leads into
the the proposal that you'll see
we also have uh obviously the list of
buildings
and conservation area uh all through the
high street there
uh but otherwise it's fairly
unrestrained um
is there any others i've missed out and
of course we've got the settlement
boundary this is just along the edge of
the settlement boundary
the seven boundaries on the north and
west boundaries of the site
and that's the official site location
plan
again very unusual shape but part of the
explanation to that is the allocation
within
the neighbourhood plan which is equally
that unusual shape
so the neighborhood plan again matches
the proposal before you matches the
allocation the neighbor plan required
69 dwellings and that is what is
proposed
and all the elements on the indicative
plan within the neighborhood plan
are what is before us and in the
locations that the neighbourhood plan
suggests
now they have some of these have already
been uh
secured by the outline that includes the
access and the attenuation basing in
part
and we also have the footpath link to
where the conservation area starts as
well
that's the site layout the scheme itself
given the layout platter the the site
location plan
there's only one place you can put the
housing i know it's in that section
there
we have a open green to the front and we
have the attenuation basin to the
north
we have a snapshot of the housing types
a wide mix of materials use of bay
windows
throughout to add character and texture
we have half hit roof garages as well
which again is a a nice character point
introduced but essentially they are you
know fairly simple
dwellings quite attractive in that
context
so we do have the affordable housing
which is indicated
on that plan if it's not clear enough
majority of the affordable housing is
to the west of the site
and scattered across different
roads there
we also have the landscape plan i'm sure
that's not been very it's not very clear
uh on a power point it goes from a very
large plan getting reduced down to
the size it has to be reduced but it
does indicate all of the
species and planting necessary and has
gone through your place service
console team
i thought it'd be useful to have a close
up of the
layout plan the main road is a standard
5.5 metre road coming into the site
and that will be adopted the orange not
on here at the moment you'll see orange
in a minute
and the white will be adopted and the
red
which you can see on this plan will be
private road
off shooting the adoption road
only one dwelling in the entire scheme
has triple parking and that is
this one here uh number
50 or lost the number it doesn't matter
but it's yeah number 54.
um but the third space or the garage
in this case is actually surplus to
highways requirements so we could just
delete the garage
and it would be in compliance with the
the highway requirements anyway
so we don't feel that would
we should fall foul on that in this
particular instance but i will leave
that for members debate
then we've got the other side so we have
the
orange bits here which obviously is a
change of materials but still adopted
and the element here will be still
adopted and the private roads
in terms of the darker red colour and we
have the link through
to chapel road or lane
which would then lead you into the rest
of bolster
along the edge here we have majority
bungalows
from the road just there
just very quickly go through the house
types just
which are in your papers
there are no chimneys i will say
and views um like i said it is a field
um and it's the main context to put into
the
to this is that these are the bungalows
running along the top end of the site
so
i'll just click through those so from
chapel lane that's the view
from from chapel lane to the site where
the footpath will be
through there
so that area of half standing was
essentially that area there
and then you'd be looking through uh but
the views across uh means you can see
these bungalows and the backs of those
at this moment in time um
so this is reserve matters uh and the
recommendation is for approval
as per your papers thanks
i just checked on slide eight of our
pack it says multiple they look to me
like multiple triple parking
so so is slide eight is it just the way
it's come out of
the printer or is it that they've
changed it
well i i needed to uh to take a height
look
the problem with the um taking
pictures from our uniform system and
putting them across into a powerpoint
is you lose the resolution sometimes and
i think that's what's happened here
because of
the nature of the drawing so for example
um
the these kind of look like they might
be double lines but actually
they're extended they're longer than
average car parking spaces they are just
one parking space but they are longer
than average
um but so and that therefore on the low
resolution it almost implies there
should be another space there but
it doesn't look quite right um
yep oh sorry one way
uh that one yeah so
i'm particularly interested in the
middle the middle
so these are one two one two
so they're two not three
and again these are one two one two
i admit i had to uh use a real close-up
on the
screen or to go around the whole estate
to try and find other than the one i
found
out
no there's one two they are longer than
average spaces the two
um but they are
i don't know that i'm afraid that's the
drawing i had as the most up-to-date
drawing
okay so so is there anything just a
question
uh i think it would be very difficult
because equally you
if they wanted to they could extend
their driveway all the way to the back
of their gardens
um
slide eight angled have we got slide
eight
which where am i going one way
do you mean the original this one um
that one
okay that's not going to help us the
slide in our pat i'm just nervous and
slide 8 in our pack it shows multiple
triple parking
very clearly defined
but i just want to make sure and now
you're saying no they're long
two car parking i hope that isn't a way
of
it hasn't changed from long two to three
but we'll
ask the applicant ultimately in terms of
the
highway guidance that we are working to
this complies with the number of spaces
even if they put the third space in yeah
i mean
i know we know we know that and so does
triple parking but this committee
generally has not accepted triple
parking as an acceptable form of
development
so that's why i just want to be really
clear um obviously you have got one
on this plan on the latest plan showing
a triple parking
if members consider that to be
inappropriate if i go back to it there's
one
yes one again i would ask that members
if they wish to alter that one singular
point
uh we we can we would happy to maybe
look at that again with a developer
uh if we were to be dedicated authority
to do so
and we can probably because there's
enough space there to uh
basically put them side by side um
possibly without any harm or anything
else there is actually a possible
solution there
on that one thank you okay any other
questions
yes councilman um
yeah john can you tell me how much
visitor parking there is on this
proposed development please
thank you
not immediately but can i look that up
again and come back to you i'm sorry
this is not being my case i didn't have
that
immediately to have
uh thank you um uh
so with all that thing um i was i've
lost
uh can you just let this council matthew
go first because i've lost the plot with
that long conversation about the parking
council mats thank you um yeah i
we introduced the the um the concept of
concurrent
submission of the um resource and energy
statement um relatively recently
unfortunately
so presumably the same thing applies to
this one
does it also apply that the the
applicant has not brought forward
um proposals for that uh to how to meet
that condition
i'm not aware that they have come
forward with that and it's not required
until prior to commencement of the
development
it's it so prior to commencement yeah
only
right yeah there's no evidence on the
the on the
layouts as far as i can see that they've
taken into account orientation for
example
and i wonder what the the slope of the
land is in this case
but perhaps that will be for the all the
ward members not here either is she
um ultimately the orientation of the
properties is part of the layout which
is before you
which is the reserve matter
the mantra back to you uh thank you um
i've i've now made a note of what i
wanted to ask
um firstly could you uh point out the
location of the affordable houses on a
plan
i think i might have seen it in the
papers and i can't find it now
could you tell me if the little patch of
trees and grass
between the cycle link and chapel lane
is that a bit of public open space
um and um uh what are your comments
about the parish council's um objection
about the policy 15 of the boston ricky
hall neighborhood plan
which states planning applications
should be appropriate to
demonstrate how they satisfy the
requirements of development design
checklists and appendix 4
thank you
john over to you
so i heard that work plan then uh so
that's the ownership
plan might be clear in your papers um
which shows me the location
of the shared ownership and the
affordable housing the shared ownership
is in red and the
blue is the affordable rent properties
does that help it does it does
i did think they are all in the same
area of the development
they are in a similar area to the
development so as you come through to
this
uh cul-de-sac arrangement you have got
affordable housing uh on the left and
you've got a market housing on the right
you do have a market housing up here as
well um so they are integrated in that
context
as you come around here they are in a
group
of their own on this point although they
are fronting
the established market housing of the
rest of the village
and they open green uh in front
we then have the public right-of-way
going through at that point
that's established under the outline so
that
would be a green space there we also
then have the public open space
area here as well so that's those two
points
and they get picked up and that bit with
the trees on in front of the
affordable houses and chapel and that is
public
that would be public space as well
alongside the the other as well
uh so that picks up on those two points
um
that's probably exposed checklist yes
the the interesting thing about that the
bottom down labour plan
um is the timing of when it was adopted
uh ultimately the outline had already
been approved prior to
the allocation and the policy
so we're in this dilemma that we're
effectively ahead of the
we had the outline that we've already
got to consider with all of the elements
that that involved
including the housing that was already
part of that
outline and then we've got the reserve
matters that's come in after
the neighborhood plan so some parts of
the checklist
cannot be complied with because the
outline
has already essentially dealt with some
of those issues and we can't go back
so a lot of the access issues which
would have been picked up under the
design checklist
we can't go back to now because it's
part of the outline
where we have been able to we have
got to where we've got to with that
design checklist as far as we can
but it is not entirely in compliance
with that policy
can i just ask is there a representative
from the parish council here today that
i can talk to
i just wondered whether there was
something specific in this design
checklist that they're all upset about
but obviously we don't know that
i will say one other thing if i may uh
chum um
we did have a meeting with the parish
council uh myself and the case officer
uh to go through the relevant elements
of that
checklist and we have spoken to the
agent who amended their plans
as best as could given the constraints
to the outline
in order to match as many things in that
checklist as possible
i'm not trying to say we did as best we
can but i think we tried our best here
to meet that
but we can't deny that there are
elements in that justice that just
cannot be dealt with because
we're in between two applications here
any other questions yes so sorry to go
on about this checklist
has the developer submitted a design
statement
um indicating where they have and have
not complied with the checklist
no you say that last but again where
they have or have not complied with that
as i understand it the parish council
are seeking
a design statement indicating
how this development either complies or
does not comply with
the um the policy 15 have they submitted
that design statement they haven't i'm
not required to either
okay next question then um we've been
told that the mppf now includes beauty
i haven't seen that new addition does
that have
any impact on this
design issue that we're looking at
before you as the reserve matters of
appearance if you consider the
appearance of these buildings
not to be beautiful that is your debate
and your
direct diversion
so there's no no further detail the mpp
as to
what constitutes beauty
there is there are various changes to
the design element of it and i will
point out we only got this yesterday
we there are links to the national
design guidance
and there are links to the national
design code
but ultimately there is
a point of debate and subjectivity that
you still have
sorry one further point if i may i did
look at policy 15
and in that the way i read it the
policy required a design statement
why why are the developer not required
to comply
with that policy which is in a made
neighborhood plan because this isn't a
planning application
this is a reserved matters application
and ultimately the only thing we have
reserved under the planning application
is appearance at scale layout
and landscaping we can require it for
the outline
but we can't require it for the reserve
matters
thank you any other question
uh yes councilman yeah i don't suppose
there's any
um any evidence of how they're
proposing to heat them and uh is is
ricky hall bottister on
on the gas grid does anybody know is
there going to be a temptation to
connect to it
i i believe it's not i guess
okay no other questions so we'll move on
um so we don't have a parish council
representative or an object
or a supporter or the agent or the
applicant
and the ward member jessica fleming
can't attend in person
but she has sent the following statement
in which i'll read
thank you for hearing my statement um
i'd like to make the following statement
i'm sorry i can't appear at the
committee um
jessica's not feeling 100 didn't want to
risk coming in
i'm free i am guided mainly by
correspondence from the parish council
contacts from the local residents and
general observations about this
application as it has developed
the parish council has objected to the
amended design on the basis that they do
not conform to policy 15
of the bottasdale and rickenhall
neighborhood plan design considerations
the applicant does not appear to have
engaged proactively with the parish
council
and local community about design and
about the neighborhood plan content
a process which might have resulted in
more widely accepted proposals being
brought forward
with the resultant better relationships
with the community
it is recognized that the applicant is
engaged with the planning authority
note 1 page 193 however the substance of
these meetings are not referenced back
to this application
therefore it is not clear what advice
may have been given or accepted
previous parish council objections
referred mainly to appendix 4 of the
neighbourhood plan which lists a number
of criteria
and expectations for new development
within the plan area
the applicant has provided a statement
on neighborhood plan
posted on the 11th of may 2021 which
is short and general and does not
address specific design
elements which appear to have been
overlooked collaboration between the
applicant and community on key elements
the neighborhood plan
would have been a good way to foster
positive support for a project such as
this
which will leave behind a lasting
influence on this area
it is clearly impractical to make
substantive changes to the design at
this stage
as the proposals are now recommended for
a peer approval
however i would like to make a request
with regards to the specific
pre-commencement conditions
19 compliance with ecology assessment
and 20
lighting scheme on page 191
as these conditions stand to affect the
special character and biodiversity
values of the area
if possible may future proposals to
discharge these conditions come back to
the parish council
for review even if informal i think this
would be greatly appreciated locally
thank you for listening jessica fleming
well actually i wanted to to ask a
question for a bit of clarification now
that i've got
bottasdale's neighborhood plan policy 15
i've located it and it's got a number of
sub parts could the officer
just tell me which of those parts from a
to k
um can be adhered to because they're not
part of the outline
and which ones are part of the outline
and can't be um
adhered to
in addition to this though there's the
design checklist itself
which is in the appendix right
that's the part that we are saying has
difficulties being fully complied with
um in terms of the main policy itself
and i've got it in front of me as well
most of this is um
subject subjective judgment on the
design merits
that is before you um but the design
checklist itself is more specific
the um if you want me to go through them
i can there is a lot here though um
obviously there's a subjective judgment
of whether or not the
design of the buildings recognizes the
characteristics of the landscaping
we have modern bungalows along the
boundary i would not want to replicate
on this site um so in that context
you have to look generally across
ottersdale and it is not
considered that these designs would be
that overly out of keeping
as modern houses um maintain the village
center place
um the site is quite constrained by the
allocation itself in terms of the
indicative plan that shows specifically
where to put
open space attenuation basin and housing
especially to fit in 69
houses and on that basis it complies
with the
allocation indicative plan and that's
the lead that the applicant has taken
so we don't feel there's a conflict
there there is no loss of gardens
um proposed because it's developing new
gardens
um so
incorporate sustainable design and
construction measures and energy
efficiency measures
on that one there is a conflict on the
basis of we're back to the same
issue we've already conditioned that
point under the outline
so in the reserve matters we can't deal
with that now so
that's going back to that argument that
we've had before
um taking medication measures into
account
historic character again the judgment of
whether you feel that the designs before
you
affect the conservation area
detrimentally in your viewpoint
we don't feel they do we don't have
anything from heritage to say that they
do
moving on important views in inside and
outside of the village
again do you feel the design
the landscaping is sufficient that is
before you to determine
uh in terms of the views you know or out
of the village
we don't consider this to be detrimental
sufficiently to refuse
and on that basis we're not recommending
to go against that part of the policy
um the amenities adjacent areas by
reasons of noise smell vibration
overlooking again we're not considering
that any parts of this application
um offends those sufficiently
beyond the expectation this is going to
be a housing estate that is allocated
on this site there will be a change to
noise to existing residents immediately
along the boundary
because you've gone from a field to a
housing estate but
to the point of refusal we feel this has
been sufficiently addressed
um i'm just looking for the rest here
um again i would probably say f
g h that complies with highway standards
apart from triple parking possibly on
one
plot the raw character existing load
unfortunately i would argue that you get
to the point where they are
fairly generic design aspirations and we
don't feel as officers
but you can have an alternative opinion
that this offends uh any of those
elements
can i just ask a couple of questions
john um
so so for whatever reason the applicants
decided not to engage with the parish
council
uh uh according to press council and the
fact they're not here today
sends the similar message that they're
not they don't want to engage with this
committee
to me they have submitted a outline
ownership plan on page 204 on our papers
which shows i'm sorry but it does show
multiple three
triple parking it's all over that
drawing
and that drawing is is which they
submitted which shows the red
the blue to rem they've filled that in
they have colored that in
they have shown the various plots this
is their drawing
and so we've got that on one side slide
nine
again shows triple parking in some
locations
less locations than slide eight you're
telling us
it's extended to bay parking now
uh the applicant isn't here for us to
ask them questions
design policy 15 on design
considerations while it's not
obligatory it would be the right thing
to do when you're working with a
community which we're here to represent
so can we defer this application and ask
that that is sorted out because
because to me we're being asked to
decide something that's incomplete
so you've got two issues there one is
engagement with the community
they are not obligated to engage with us
or the community and that would not be
i would say a reason to defer or refuse
the application it's not material and
planning terms
in respect of the drawings i apologize
if we have failed to ensure that the
drawings are updated
to the most up-to-date plan that shows
no triple parking with the exception of
that one plot
that i will take on board as an apology
from officers
and i i don't necessarily think that
might be the fault of the applicant i
think that's our fault for maybe not
ensuring that you had up-to-date plans
or they weren't clear enough in your
papers
i do know we have resolution issues with
transferring data
but i apologize in this case in terms of
the policy on the terms of the one plan
you have there
that you pointed out it shows ownership
it's not intended to show parking
um so it should be taken as an ownership
plan in terms of where the locations of
affordable housing will be
please don't take it as the parking plan
policy 15 design
the the the the you know
in terms of fitting in with the um
you know the the boston style request
that having some sort of input there's
no requirement planning law that has to
require
the input of a parish council or any
community
group okay the applicants do not have to
engage
it is highly encouraged within the nppf
highly highly encouraged
it's not required and it's not required
in any planning law either
it's not and unfortunately policies even
in
naval plans can't require it either
you know i think it's really
disappointing someone and we're not in
debate now so i'll come on to it
uh council pass is there any more
questions before we get into debate
that was the question i was going to ask
you would be obviously and i was going
to say i think
um there ought to be grounds to defer
this because if we haven't got the
correct documents here
the latest ones i'm not it's not
question of blaming anyone john but the
fact is
how can you make a decision if we don't
see it in front of us so therefore
i think there's plenty of legitimate
grounds even if it was just related to
parking to say we should defer it
and i'm i would also echo matthew's
point of view there
whatever the requirements in the law and
the compliance about consulting them
it's a bit crass
as not to go and consult with the parish
and do what you can to work with
communities
and as matthew says and i think we all
agree regardless of our political
position here we are there to represent
our communities
and be failing in our job so whilst
the question i was going to say i think
we do have grounds to defer this
so i just wanted to answer to that which
i suspect you've already answered
to matthew but i would if we get to the
debate i would be inclined to suggest we
do move to defer it
for those reasons also this issue about
beauty it's a very interesting concept
we could debate it all day long
and i personally think i would have a
difficulty saying it is a beautiful
design
perhaps that would satisfy the
difference
thank you chair um personally i i
am i don't have a problem with the
parking map um
i saw i thought we were in debate oh
sorry i i'm sorry
it was really offering a view on the
parking of so on you know
so so are there any grounds for us to
defer this
based on what we're being asked before
we go into debate
john and ian please so in terms of the
plans
before you um looking closely i've had
to zoom in
uh to the ownership plan for example you
are quite correct there is lots of
triple parking shown
on that plan we then move on to
the more up-to-date plans that has been
removed
the distances i'm just trying to quickly
measure
well they moved
yeah they basically what's happened is
they've clearly taken
the triple parking was going into the
garden um
especially for a number of plots
[Music]
just looking at that one for plots um 13
14 15 16 in the middle they're no longer
going into the garden so they have
reduced
that whole space back
some of them are slightly longer than
you may be expected as an average
parking space these tend to be around
the main
estate road plots 54 for example
but the issue here is you do have
sets of plans that are different from
each other in terms of the parking show
can you give these possibly chair can i
ask for a moment break with our legal
my colleagues just to ask for advice
sorry i just can't resist to add
something to that surely our point is
that if triple parking is necessary to
meet the county requirements
that is unacceptable to this committee
but if
if with not with the double parking you
can meet the county requirements
i would suggest that's acceptable and if
people
are able to park three cars on their
drive rather than two on their drive and
one on the
pavement i can't see that that's an
issue that
could cause this committee a great
problem
as long as there's visitor parking as
long as you don't have to triple park
to meet the standards just a question
what is the county's standard for
visitor park
is there a standard
can i just follow and therefore based on
that which of these drawings is showing
the correct visit to parking that we
should be looking at because if it's not
on slide eight what which one is it
um i'm gonna have to apologize here um
i've now reviewed the whole lot again
there should be visitor parking because
you essentially gain a visitor space for
every number of houses
um i can't see any visitor parking shown
on this plan
and i think on that basis that would be
a clear reason for
us to go away in itself councilman
um on the plan on page 202 which i've
got blown up on my screen
there are four five six
seven eight nine ten uh at least ten
i've just seen a glance um
oh it's called dc 2003098 drb
6902f proposed site layout the most
up-to-date one from the webpage
uh i think it's called proposed site
layout color was where i got it 11th of
may 2021
and i think that is the same as the one
we've got on page 202.
sorry i can't hear you so
if i go back to the close-ups i should
have had uh wrong way
so these two close-ups are the most
up-to-date colored in plan
layout according to our system and i'm
so where was the where the right there's
at the bottom of the plan
there's a row of three trees just above
that there are
two parking spaces uh with c on them
i believe those visitor parking spaces
so am i the right place here
down the bottom of the map three there's
three trees in the line
sorry there's two there i think the
other ones are on the other half of the
map
right so we've got there's a lot of two
there
um so i
changed one way i just don't think i
think we're sort of
scrubbing around to try and find it here
and i think you know if we're going to
make a decision on this
on something of this scale we really
need it in our paper
so you've got the visitor spaces are
actually there so my mistake
there's like so there's some there and
there's some on the other side
okay we'll just take a two minute break
so they can just work through the
papers
and so having taken some advice
we're going to allow the applicant like
all speakers to have up to three minutes
to speak
and then we have the opportunity to ask
questions as we would normally
so i'm happy to hand over that to speak
for up to three minutes
you can hear me okay yeah adam bell
benny holmes i just came today to
observe i wasn't intending to speak and
not prepared to do so
but in light of some of the confusion
that
has taken place i thought i'd offer my
self for questions
um on relating to the parking
uh the plans were revised to avoid the
triple parking and to provide all the
visitor parking so
there may be some discrepancy in your
papers but the
parking has been complied with and
i believe suffolk county council are
happy with the
parking proposals i haven't really got
anything more to say so i'll probably
end it there and if you've got any
questions i'll
try and answer them for you thank you
okay questions for the app console can
you tell us how many visitor parking
spaces there
are i think unfortunately i haven't got
that
that my fingertips but all i can say is
that that's been taken account of and
the
and the provision has been provided on
site that the required
number has been provided
um yeah thanks matthew one of the
questions i want to know i know there's
no compulsion on this but
what liaison have you had with the
parish council local residents to get
get them on board with what you're
proposing
um we've not had any face-to-face
meetings with the parish
uh there have been a few emails between
us over the
long periods that the application's been
in
we've been asked to take account of the
neighbourhood plan in this policy 15
which we
have done so with which we've done and
we've reviewed that we produced a
statement which i think the chairman
read out he referred to that in the uh
in the ward councillor's
statement i think it was referred to so
we've we've been through all of the
policy
and explained how we've
tried to comply with it
bearing in mind the fact that this is a
reserved matters application and
many of the principles which are
outlined in the
neighbourhood plan have already have
already been
established or or cannot be established
because
of the the location for example in the
situation of the site
councilman uh thank you um chair
um seeing as we now have a
representative from the
applicant um can i ask some further
questions about
um i noticed that we have an informative
on our recommendation about sustainable
development principles but
can you give me any indication about how
these houses are to be heated
and do you intend to provide ev
charging points for every dwelling
the heating will be by sorc pumps um
i think pretty much all of our homes now
are heated by soc pumps and
i think from 2023 uh
gas boilers are going to be um obsolete
so
so heat pumps um
what was your other question recharging
charging points
we we often do provide them i'm not sure
if they're a requirement on this scheme
if we're required to do so we will
provide them
thanks uh yeah
thank you mr chair um just looking on
google maps the um
the line of houses to the north of this
site parkview i think they're probably
local authority homes but every single
one has got
solar panels on the roof so this would
seem to be an ideal site for that sort
of technology
are you planning to put any on the roofs
of the houses in this new development
uh we're we're not um we're complying
with
uh building regulations and and all
the planning policies we provide we're
gonna heat the homes with air source
heat pumps we leave
photovoltaics and that type of
technology to
our purchases to install if they want
them or if they don't but we're not
proposing to put in ourselves
any yes councilman yeah in light of that
answer i mean i was going to ask
very very similar question actually um
would you be prepared to to offer um
the option of of photovoltaics being
installed
um where people are buying off plan only
i mean there's a there's a large
um benefit in making it much
cheaper and easier to fit them when
you've got the scaffolding up
than it is to have come and come and put
the scaffolding up
the the next year
like it's not something we offer a
standard
standard i'm saying we would we couldn't
entertain it uh the difficulty is
normally uh our buyers don't get
don't don't see the the property uh
until it's you know got the roof on and
it's
almost complete it's plastered so
those sort of decisions need to be made
at a very early stage and it's unlikely
that
buyers will be in contact with us at
that early stage
and you just want to come around the
parking place the visitor parking
because that's
something we're going to need yeah so in
an effort to redeem myself
i've just had to look through the whole
plan um
there are in fact 18 visitor parking
spaces
managed to find them they're quite hard
to find because the way the landscaping
is indicated in the
the line under the landscaping but
essentially
17 is your requirement under the suffolk
county council
guidance and you've got 18 and they are
dotted throughout
the layout plan if you like i can go
through each one but
um they are on the plan well i think if
you've had the chance now to run through
it or you've that's the
that's the answer there are 18 and
there's only one property with triple
parking that's you know we take that as
red now i think
uh councilman could i just ask
mr payton g if it if it is uh uh
feasible allowable for us to um
an ev charging condition if we are
minded to approve this application
normally i'd say no but
i did notice that in the previous
application
there was so i will
i don't know now so i'm going to take it
as the council has made one decision in
that context
i'll let that i don't know what has to
say
okay any other questions for the
applicant and thank you for making
yourself known
um especially when we were all
discussing
your comp your your application okay so
thank you very much
okay members so that's now um all the
information before us up to us discuss
debate and reach a conclusion
casa madison i i was rather struck by
the
the similarities in what in what council
fleming was saying
in her email regarding bringing the um
how a couple of the conditions which i
did have open earlier
um 190 something wasn't it
um that she was asking that they might
be brought to the
to the parish council to look at i see
that the
it was ecology and lighting i think
wasn't it she mentioned
um there is there is actually something
um the report the report from our
ecology advisor is
is um is already is available with the
outline
um so that's that's come
that's earlier than it had to be let's
just
speak but i was particularly struck that
the
the lighting scheme had to be brought
forward prior to occupation
but i i just i wonder that that we
perhaps would do better better now than
we did then but
um the you would think that the design
of the lighting scheme would need
to to be in place a great deal earlier
than occupation
in practice and i find all that a bit
puzzling
and um and obviously my
uh we're still in the same position that
we haven't got
the how the uh how the applicant is
going to
to really address climate change fully
i mean air source heat pumps are the
standard thing if there's no gas
there but um i'm
i think i think we have to do better
with that not
necessarily affecting this this one
before us now but
um the stage at which some of these
things are sorted out in relation to
to design um
needs to be in front of the applicant
and thought about when that when they're
preparing the reserve
matters uh not at the last minute or
or prior to occupation john do you want
to come in and then
yeah actually the lighting is quite a
difficult one so there's various
lighting
uh conditions uh some refer to any
lighting that isn't part of the
residential dwellings
this one actually covers everything um
now
because it covers everything it covers
all the domestic garden lights it covers
uh all the different paths that are
privately controlled
it also controls all of the adopted road
lighting
potentially now the adoptive road
lighting would be something that they
would have to have a discussion with the
county at a very late stage
so in in one sense being prior to
occupation is quite a sensible time
frame
because there's quite a lot of different
lighting components
that probably need to be agreed before
they can actually put a total scheme in
for approval
and that's to include the adopted road
as well as all the private gardens
and any walkways in between
ultimately the point is if they don't
have a scheme
agreed they're not allowed any lighting
externally which is the whole point to
protect the bat population and the
locality
which is the reason for this particular
condition because it's about ecology
uh not like pollution specifically it's
more about the sensitivity of uh
wildlife in the area i can't change that
condition
ultimately it is prior to occupation and
is what is before us
yeah well yeah i think you know that's
it's interesting that the different
sorts of lighting are all tied up in
there
in there together um you know perhaps
you could
kind of take away and think in general
terms about how
these these various design issues and
obviously the the
energy and resource one is the one
that's uppermost and we've agreed that
that's now should be
concurrent with which is good um i just
wonder whether
the concurrent width can be you know
that the lighting that
that needs to be designed in et cetera
et cetera would be sorted out
concurrent with etcetera as well uh just
to give that a bit of bit of um
thought really thank you
quick question john i mean for me and
we're in debate now for me
um the biggest issue was the triple
parking
uh the biggest issue is lack of
engagement with the parish council
though the lack of engagement with the
parish council
there's not much we can do about it not
conforming to policy 15 of the
neighborhood plan
it's just really hugely disappointing
but if that's the
business approach of bennett homes
there's nothing we can do about that
that's just the way it is
and there's nothing the parish council
can do so you know
there's nothing here that i can find
reasons for refusing it
but it doesn't mean i like it but my
question is
can i or how can we
at the request of councillor fleming
look at what
discussions can take place between us
and the parish council in some of the
discharging of conditions
or is that just i mean normally we
wouldn't do that because once it's
approved it's approved
uh but what are your thoughts on that so
discharging conditions are applications
in their own right
um we
[Applause]
we do consult do we hang on
i don't think parish councils are
automatically consulted but we have done
in the past um i did that with walpip um
recently on on some bits pieces so there
is no reason why we
can't make a note to ensure that we
following any further
conditions on this particular site that
we do inform
the parish council if the parish council
has signed up to our
website in a particular way they
automatically should
get consulted anyway from any uh
application that comes forward in that
parish but um i can take that away with
us that's not a problem
thank you councilman um
in the paperwork the parish council
states that they find the buildings
bland
and lacking in local um distinctiveness
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
well here
the people on the ground think those
buildings are bland and lacking in
distinctiveness
now the mppf has changed and it includes
a
section on beauty i believe we have got
grounds
to refuse this on
the fact that the the
buildings are bland and lack
distinctiveness
and to overcome this will encourage the
developers
to engage with the parish council to
agree
a set of criteria that um remove
their concern we represent the people on
the ground and they don't like these
buildings
so i i may be completely
wide of the mark but i think we do have
grounds and to get around that
we would encourage the developer to
engage with the parish council
shoot me down john um
maybe this is a solution um
given that this guidance note came out i
think was it yesterday we had that email
about
beauty and it was very subjective as we
all said
i do wonder whether there are actually
grounds to defer this application
because we are concerned about the
aspect of beauty or however we want to
put it
and therefore would urge the applicant
to consult with the parish council to
come up with a solution
based on the reasonable grounds that
when the applicant
first put the application in this
information hadn't come to light now i
don't know how this works out
as a lawful process but i'm trying to be
helpful not to reject it and i do agree
with you matthew your comments earlier
maybe this is a way forward because the
applicant wouldn't have known about this
email that arrived from the secretary of
state
yesterday or the day before so on that
basis i would like to propose that we
defer this application which i think
will enable us to take account of those
issues
so that's a formal proposal to defer it
uh uh thank you chair i mean i don't um
i do share some of the views of the
other counselors who've spoken
but on the face of it for this
particular site
i don't think this is that bad an
application
i think it's a very contrived site but
it's got outline permission anyway
houses are going to go here um i think
it's regrettable
that the applicant has not it fully
engaged with the parish council
and i think the um the adoption
of the neighborhood plan between the
outline
and the reserve matters sort of muddied
it a bit and then made it much more
complicated for us to deal with that
policy 15 and all that all that list
the parking is compliant there is only
one
instance of triple parking i'm not quite
sure why because that plot is huge and
they could easily fit a side-by-side
parking place but that's
neither here nor there we can't refuse
it on that
the houses are not particularly
interesting
i'm not sure i mean i prefer them to
ones that have pretending to be things
they're not at least they don't have
false chimneys
um so i'm i'm i'm not convinced
that we have got grounds for refusal
they are adequate they're not on the gas
um they're meeting all of the
requirements as you say beauty is in the
eye of the beholder so
what is beauty to one is not to another
um
so i'm uh i i'm not i
i'm i'm not in fate i never like
deferring things i'd rather make a clean
sweep clean decision here and now but
um i'll listen to what others have got
to say
while you were talking tim pasmore has
proposed
formally to defer based on the fact that
we've had new information come in from
the secretary of state
since the first up since this first week
did the rounds and obviously
since the application was even submitted
and since the papers were issued for
this committee
yeah and um the reason we were talking
was because we were trying to work out
if we would cause ourselves a problem in
that that wasn't a reason to defer the
first item on the agenda
in terms of in terms of lawful
and risk of challenge in that respect
council field you were next
i mean i planned to go with the council
of mass or on this
i'm afraid um
if if we defer on the on the grounds
that we
need to consider whether these houses
are beautiful or not
we have to accept that we don't have a
local
design code in place as yet as far as
i'm aware
there is obviously a generic government
one that has been released
so how we're going to determine whether
these are acceptable designs
to me they look reasonable
basic that they obviously are not
uh make believe saxed cottages or
whatever
the parish council wants and i i have no
idea what they want
so that's an unreasonable comment
perhaps but
i'm inclined to go with the thought that
this is is not a bad development it has
addressed the
issues of parking which would rightly
have
concerned us greatly we would all
perhaps
prefer to see i say all
a number of us councillors would like to
see the orientations
picked appropriate for solar gain
and the insulation levels and
heat sources similarly selected
but most of that is not currently within
the building regulations and we're
informed that we
can't make those demands okay so i'm
inclined to
accept this as it is okay i'm going to
listen yeah so what i i'm we're sort of
covering we don't want to cover the old
ground so we've got a proposal for
deferment we haven't got a seconder
do i have a seconder for that was that
going to fail
do i have a second uh yeah you want to
second that
okay so do anyone else want to speak on
that item before we go to the vote and
then i'll bring in council mellon who
was next
so just on deferment yeah i'd just like
to
to really question what we're going to
gain um if we're deferring it
on terms of we don't think these houses
are beautiful do we really think that
the developer is going to come back
and beautify all of these houses in a
month's time and we'll come back and
we'll have the same old debate again
i'm not convinced that we will gain
anything by deferring
okay and on the the deferred matter you
wish to come in customer
yeah i'm just picking up a point um on
design guys the parish has
some design criteria they believe that
these houses
are bland i believe we should support
them
you know we we have in many other cases
um supported neighborhood plans and i
think we should here
so i i take um councillor's point
but i support the parish council and
their
opinion that these are planned okay so
the
the first vote is for deferment on those
grounds yes
john can i uh provide some professional
advice on the decision you're about to
make
can i suggest respectfully to the member
who've made the proposal
that it is altered not to refer to the
nppf in the context of the beautiful
element but you are looking for design
considerations in respect of appearance
that is before you today to be
considered
and i would add perhaps that you may
wish to ask
us to check over the plans to ensure
that they are up to date and match
and also to compare the design policy of
the nppf
and provide members with a robust
rundown
of that policy against the proposal
before you
okay so on that basis yeah yeah i i
really spoke in terms of of second
councilman's proposal
um i mean the the the other thing that i
would look at again and i think council
field hinted at it as well
is is you know i think it's mppf 148
that asks the um that the development
actually
makes the best use of the site and i
think the orientation
point is part of that part i don't know
what the
slow the gradient of this land is but
the
the orientation of the buildings is
using the site in the best way
and and in energy terms it isn't
is it 148 john i think
okay i know the paragraph you're
referring to but uh it is
we can yes uh about the orientation to
maximize efficiency
111 but but ironically all those policy
numbers have changed in the new mppf so
um i know that's important
yeah i'm going gonna try and leave this
on councilman did you want to come in
because you were very patient did you
want to come in on this point before we
go to the very
yeah hopefully it's relevant i just want
to raise something that i don't think
anyone else has raised and
which jumps out to me is that i think
the we're dealing with landscaping
appearance
layout it seems to me that the homes on
the northern end of this are very very
close to the other
house homes and there isn't much of a
buffer in the landscaping
um and that to me is a bit of an issue
there's potential loss of amenity for
the
for the other the neighboring properties
so that's just another consideration to
throw into the mix
okay so we've had the reasons laid out
by council pastoral council matheson
as the reasons for uh deferring this
we go to the vote on that please
thank you chad i've just put that into
the um
mod gov system now
okay members your vote reads the
application
number dc203098 be deferred to allow
officers to ensure all plans match
in detail explore improvements to
appearance than for officers to provide
analysis of design
policy of neighbourhood plan
number 15 and append design checklist
so that vote is now in progress
thank you
is
so if i could take your vote verbally
for deferral thank you so that's six
votes four
and two against here that's carried
you very much okay so we're going to
move
straight on to the next application uh
dc2100522
um harry goodrich are you going to move
seats or do it from
we need to just clean that if you can do
you can sit in the middle seat
uh you're allowed three up on that top
for the distancing
okay so we now move on to the last
application before us dc2100522
land south of little owl lodge ashfield
road norton
and now invite the case officer harry
goodrich to introduce the application to
the committee
over to you thank you chair
so here we have an application at land
south of little
lodge in norton for one three bed
dwelling
so the site is in norton little green
which is sort of separate from norton
itself
it's not considered as part of norton in
the core strategy policy cs01
so it is considered countryside in
policy terms
the site is approximately one mile from
the services available in norton to the
west
and around three miles from elmsville to
the east
so the site location shows access drawn
past hayden's
and access past hayden sorry to the east
it's a backland development largely
beyond the existing built form
the site is closely related to the grade
two listed hayden's
and it is outside the built up
settlement boundary of norton little
green itself
so here we have a block plan showing an
l-shaped dwelling with two parking
spaces
off to the side and the previously
previously developed buildings to the
north
obviously here we have the elevations
proposed including traditional
agricultural materials
with timber boarding and clay plant pen
tiles
so we have the floor plan there just
showing the three bedrooms
and now we just have a number of photos
this is showing the neighbor to the west
and showing the open nature of the sort
of plots in the locality
then we have a photo of the location of
the actual dwelling itself
or where it's to be proposed we have
looking back from the site onto the
applicant's property and other
previously developed properties
a photo of little owl lodge there with
the sort of mixed roof
pan tiles
and then that's just a wider context
showing both the proof development to
the north and the little lodge
that's the rear boundary treatments
obviously it's quite thick and it backs
onto agricultural
fields this is facing out the access to
the east
from sorry the access to the east but
looking west
and that's the access looking east
[Applause]
and that's looking down the accessories
obviously you can see it is already in
place
so the application is recommended for
refusal on being located in the
countryside and outside of settlement
boundary
and is not considered sustainable
development is also being refused for
another reason as an impact
on the list of building known as
hayden's and its associated curtis
listed out buildings this is a low level
less than substantial harm
thank you thank you
any questions on this
yes counselor field could you just show
me on a map which is the
listed building in which it's uh
affecting and
i don't really have any photos that
allow me to form a view on that
myself so the list of buildings if i
just go back
if i just pull up the constraints map
for you
so the the hayden's is the orange one
just slightly to the north sort of north
east of the site l-shaped building
does the laser work
it's just there
i would say closer to 50 meters
do you have a photo tool that shows the
the impact of the proposed
development a photovoltaic bill of that
sorry
a photo that in any way shows the impact
of the
way sorry bested impact on that building
you know
it looks almost as though it's not
visible
they're not in the same you know
so it is just that you see that pink top
there
the pink sort of render that is the list
of building itself there
okay and obviously the access is drawn
down the side of the listed building
is there already okay thank you
okay any other questions yes council
sorry council manson it's looking at
your meaning
uh thank you chair um could the officer
just point out the location
of the uh planning inspector decision um
property that um the ward member calling
refers to
which is not whatever numbers he's
written down
i don't know the exact location of the
top of my head but that was a decision
in 2017 which was when the council
didn't have the five-year land supply
so it was decided on the tilted balance
where presumption was given in favor of
development
because we didn't have the foes maybe i
can ask um
councillor richardson where it is thank
you
uh councillor
no someone sorry tim sorry
yeah just a very quick question going
back to the listed building issue
would i be right on that photograph you
head up just there and harry that there
are other buildings that are not listed
which are closer to the listed building
than the proposed site for the
uh that we have the application before
us
i want to speak for the heritage team in
that respect but i do believe these are
this is a cartilage listed out building
yeah
and obviously this is the listed
building itself so the reason for the
harm
is the impact to hayden's itself and its
curtis listed out buildings
i would believe so i i wouldn't
any other questions okay we'll move on
um
[Applause]
right um we don't have a representative
from the parish council or
oh yeah or an objective speed but mrs
rebecca jennings
um the applicant welcome and you have
three minutes
and this is the timer here over to you
good morning thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak on behalf of our
application
we believe that the application site has
been thoughtfully placed in order to
ensure there is little or no
impact on surrounding properties the
property itself would be tucked away and
where proposed at present
would only be seen by us the applicants
the retention of
the retention of surrounding wildlife
and trees is imperative to us
and we feel the property design will
blend in and enhance the site
we have recently planted an orchard to
the north of the site incorporating
various species of fruit trees
additionally to this we have placed two
out boxes on or near the site
two bee hives on or near the site and
various bird boxes of which many to our
delight
are now in occupation the only
beneficiaries of this application would
be our daughter and her husband
both of whom are key workers and have
worked tirelessly through the pandemic
but still not in a position to offer
their three children
little more than an end to terrorist
property with a tiny garden
furthermore the surrounding site at
present has three generations of the
jennings family living
in close proximity if granted permission
this property would allow the next
generation to live closer to their
grandparents
and great grandparents and older cousins
but enable them to continue attending
their choice of education
of which they are familiar with in the
next village the application is to be
refused because it
is outside of the settlement boundary
last year a very similar site was
approved
about 120 metres to the east on appeal
the inspector disagreed that because the
site was outside the settlement boundary
it should be refused
another appeal was allowed in a similar
location 120 metres north of our site
two other applications have been
approved by the council in the last few
years in northern little green
outside of any settlement boundary a low
level of
less than substantial harm is believed
to be caused to hayden's farmhouse
the home has been designed like a barn
because the farmhouse has always had
barns on the site of the house
and has always been part of a cluster of
buildings
if benefits outweigh the harm the
permission can be approved
other houses have been approved nearby
in similar circumstances because they
provide benefits that outweigh the harm
these benefits have been providing
houses that are in need locally
economic benefits from construction
economic and social benefits from the
new families
and providing sustainably designed
houses
we will build a number of energy
efficiency measures into this house such
as rain water harvesting
solar water heating and renewable energy
and we very much hope that you will
support our application
very much any questions at all for the
applicant
no okay thank you very much thank you
for joining us
uh next we move on to the ward members
now we have two board members councillor
harry richardson councillor wendy turner
i've got a written statement from wendy
turner john do you want to go first or
second
okay so i'll read out the comment from
councillor wendy turner just to let you
know i'll be supporting in your decision
to refuse the planning application for
the above application
on the grounds that you have stated it
is outside the settlement
built up area boundary and is not in a
sustainable location
there is no suitable footpath or
psychopath to the main part of the
village
where all the amenities are located so
reliance on a car would probably be
necessary
as currently there are very few buses
best wishes wendy turner
over to you thank you very much
chair um i just thought by way of um
sort of introduction i would just
obviously point out that this is quite
an unusual
um application to be considering that
it's not often a war member calls in
a single dwelling because they think it
should be approved and i'm happy to talk
through the context as to how and why
um it came to the point where i felt the
need to call in the application
and i can pick that up in the questions
afterwards if that's helpful um but for
what i wanted to say
sort of here and now i wanted to talk
through the the merits or otherwise
um of the application itself um so just
again by way of context i think the last
time i came before this committee
um was for the horse lane application
which is also in norton
um and i think during that debate and
discussion there was numerous
councillors made the point
that they wanted to see more affordable
housing in rural communities like
norton and just did a bit of background
research yesterday
the cheapest property currently for sale
um in norton which is a four-bedroom
new
prices in south africa bui 000 which is
not exactly what i'd call an affordable
family home
um which as you've heard from the
applicant is something that's a key
consideration
for the this application as a whole um
and just picking up on what the applica
the applicant has also said
just for speaking from my perspective as
the with my
cabinet portfolio having multiple
generations of the same family living in
the immediate vicinity of one another
that's not just sort of a quaint and
nice thing to have i think there's
there's real benefits to be had
from inter in in from a well-being
perspective as far as intergenerational
living is concerned
um the other point which i think is
quite significant here is is the quality
of the design that we're looking at
personally in some respects i don't
think the drawings necessarily do it
justice
but when i look at it so it's a single
story dwelling in the style of a
traditional
suffolk uh barn with black
weatherboarding and red
red clay bricks um which i think
realistically is much much better than
what we often
get which is interesting you talk you
know fixed on that point in the previous
application
um and i think this is of wider interest
to the district and i'll come on
to talk about that later um in terms of
the actual reasons for refusal
in the report i don't think they're
especially strong
and i think the harm identified can
quite easily be mitigated
and this came out in um council of
manchester's question i'm having to
touch on that
um in the questions afterwards but
they've been five dwellings very
sorry five applications very similar to
this within norton little green in the
last
sort of two three years where you've got
exactly issues like this
vicinity to a list of building outside
the settlement boundary but
those five have been granted of which
two were inspectorate decisions
and the other three being officer
decisions so i think there's a slight
degree of inconsistency with what's in
this
um applicant what's in this
recommendation in terms of the
sustainability point
um again there is that precedent from
what the appeal inspector said initially
for the
the property was about 120 metres to the
north of this site
there is a bus stop located in this part
of the village as well
um and given the fact that you've got
multiple family members living
immediately adjacent to this property i
would imagine there's opportunities for
things like car sharing
um so i think we can we can mitigate
that to some extent
on on the open country side point i
wouldn't necessarily agree
with the conclusions in the report um
as far as i can see the piece of land
itself is not agricultural land it
offers no public communities
within the hedge row of the existing
dwelling so effectively it's just
private land that doesn't have any wider
sort of value or amenity that it offers
and again as far as the heritage is
concerned this was picked up in the
questions
i wouldn't say that this dwelling is in
the immediate vicinity of that listed
building
the cartilage is perhaps another issue
but
just looking at the application i
referred to earlier
um to the north of the site they've got
a local
very close precedent for that and
similarly within the last 12 months
and they've been similar applications in
elms well in wiveston
that centered around a very similar
problem i've got the reference numbers
for those but i can i can give you those
if you need them
um so from my perspective although there
is that
degree of distance and the question of
how much weight you attach to that
um personally i think that's something
if you were concerned about it
um you might be able to mitigate by way
of um
attaching conditions for additional
landscaping for example
um then turning which i'm always trying
to
be conscious of whenever i'm giving
representations about planning um
applications is think about okay well in
policy terms what are the reasons for
approval
so just picking out the mppf for example
there's paragraphs
78 79 and 80 which all talk about
the appropriateness of building in the
open countryside
and of rural communities more generally
so paragraph 79 talks about
um the preference for building
new dwellings where it will enhance or
maintain the vitality of rural
communities
and for part of the reasons i've talked
about with the family circumstances the
lack of affordable housing
i think this is a perfect example of
where a development is going to achieve
exactly that
um and secondly paragraph 80 talks about
the fact that you can build if it's
isolated and in the open country side
if now i don't regard this as being
isolated or in the open countryside
personally
it's my subjective view i think it's
quite close to the existing built up
area
but even if it was isolated and in the
open countryside
you do have a degree of flexibility if
you think the
design is exceptional or if it raises
the standards
of design in rural communities and i
think it does to be perfectly honest um
i would love to see
much more of this style development in
my ward
um relative to some of the larger ones
that i have in thurston
and i think this is the kind of design
we can use as a benchmark
for um the design the quality of design
that we see in future um rural
developments
and again did not know this until mr
israel mentioned it at the beginning but
i think this beauty aspect and question
comes into to to exactly that i know we
have got a technical definition for what
we mean by that
um and there's no obviously policy that
i can point to um
but i think it's a relevant point that's
worth considering
and so then just finally to wrap up um
obviously this comes down to a balance
between the benefits and the harms
um and the weight you attach to each
personally
i think the harm is very limited um
admittedly
in a similar regard the public benefits
from the application
are more limited because it's from a
single dwelling but i think the design
beauty aspect does represent a broader
benefit to the public
and although it is a purely private
benefit um the delivery of a new home
for a young family with
substantial local roots um is something
that i hope you would
support and agree something we want to
see so that's what i wanted to say chair
but i'm happy to pick up some of the
other issues
um in questions thank you thank you can
we just have clarity
because the ward members said that
they've been five applications approved
some in the last two years
on appeal that are very similar can we
just have clarity about those
applications please
no just microphone to work is that
working now
okay um can you put this yeah could you
just put the if you've got a location
plan we just put up so let's do some
identification
so the appeal uh site referenced in the
call-in
um is a 2016 reference
if i'll just if you can just show
that so that was essentially if you go
left left left left
there down that spot there so that's the
appeal site that was being referenced by
the
board member uh that was allowed on
appeal
um haven't been refused essentially that
sits within the
countryside village designation and will
be
a part of the proposed settlement in
your
upcoming joint local plan so that was
that one
the majority of the other appeals that
have been
gone forward for various sizes are
within norton itself
down the road um i've got a plan to show
you where they all are
but essentially if you go around the
corner and and keep going a little bit
they are within the main core of the
village
itself and they were
they came forward at different times one
where we didn't have a housing supply
there are some there that when we did
have a housing supply but we still have
to deal with a tilted balance
because of the out of date nature of
those proposals now of course with those
there weren't a list of buildings
involved in respect to this application
we do have a listed building involved
this makes a slight difference to the
interpretation of the nppf
in that um the tilted balance doesn't
necessarily apply
what we have here is um if
if heritage is involved then the tilted
balance
criteria in what was paragraph d it's
just
if it's still the same um it can be
pulled away and you are looking at
giving full weight to your policies on
the countryside and sustainability
ask a question were any of those other
applications outside the settlement
boundary
yes probably most of them were outside
they were mostly outside
in respect of the main core of norton
itself
but the conditions here are different in
policy terms that members will need to
take
a careful mindful of but of course the
judgment is theirs
yes councilman um thank you chair
i i am familiar with norton little green
as it used to be part of my ward
and could we just have some
clarification about
the proposed settlement boundaries in
our new joint local plan because
in the existing settlement hierarchy i
believe
the only settlement boundary in norton
goes around
the core of the village by the 1088. in
our proposed
draft joint local plan there are two
areas in northern little green which
have their own
settlement boundaries um i'm not sure
i've got the most up-to-date version
but the one i've got in front of me
looks as if this
particular site sits within
one of the proposed settlement
boundaries for norton little green
can you please confirm whether i'm right
or perhaps you could clarify the
situation thank you
yes i've got it in front of me um bear
with me a little zoom in
there's no way of showing that that's
the infield
that would be it
have you got the plan well
so what do i use as a houston church
yeah okay
so it's still outside doesn't it yes um
so
the existing rectangle building if you
can just
of the current property there that would
be inside
the settlement boundary proposed in your
joint local plan
but the site that is proposed which is
the etched area
to the south is outside want to come
back councilman
can you can you put your version uh up
on the screen please
of the settlement battery
how do i do that because the one i've
got is
it's not like that that's why i just
want to clarify i just want to see the
two separate ones
you're right maybe it's it's not the
right version
it's called joint local plan 2019 part
three
um which one have i got
let me um i'm not aware of any changes
but let me
download the latest and just check
bear with me
oh you got it is that version the same
as what i've just
yeah it's the same snaps the most up
today
okay we've got it to show
okay so this is this will only show up
internally not on the live screen
but we are just looking basically at
where the assessment boundary goes
no we'll see it on our screen but they
it won't be on there
[Music]
i've got an old one and it's got a
little kink in it that goes
down around that site that we're talking
about now but
i'm happy to agree that that is the new
version
okay thank you that gives clarity yes
i can just shed a little light on that
because a very similar situation in my
ward
appeal decision and so on and the the
there were a number of adjustments to
the settlement boundaries
in the proposed joint local plan um at a
late stage
um but the you know the key thing is
what has gone to the
the examination and i agree that
thank you uh casa field you were next
thank you but i guess the mppf says
something about
isolated homes in the countryside the
question i had really was just the
sustainability issue um the the
distance to the village is quoted as one
mile is that actually the distance to
the school
you know otherwise something which will
be accessed
a couple of times a day or or is it to
some other facilities
yes so that would be the the right
distance to the school because that's
located
pretty much in the core of norton proper
what i don't know is whether the
applicant's
family their children go to that school
that's obviously a personal context that
i'm not familiar with that's some answer
can i just clarify it's it's more like
one and a half miles
okay but the county criteria is
they pay for transport if it's more than
two
okay any other questions for the ward
member
no okay well members we've had all the
information put before us it's now up to
us to discuss debate
and come to a conclusion
come to pass more you want to right ball
right thank you chairman well
this is quite a difficult one to decide
because on the one hand
um i can understand entirely why the
officers have
recommended refusal that is their role
they have to stick to that but then we
are here as a committee
to determine what we think taking on
board their their advice
i personally can't see anything really
wrong with this application
so i would probably on balance difficult
there is
be prepared to support it because i do
think the
comments that the ward member made
regarding
enhancing local communities i think the
design is entirely appropriate it fits
and i don't want to get involved in this
argument where whether it's beautiful
or whatever but i can absolutely see how
if it does stick to that that it would
fit
so i am minded to support that i mean if
it was to be supported and i'm not
making a formal proposal at the moment
clearly there would have to be the
conditions the ecology
um sustainability arguments regarding
energy source all the usual things that
we put there that's really really
important
and i do think if it were to be approved
um then we need to try and restrict that
there's no further development
in the vicinity and i have to say the
reason i asked the question regarding
the proximity of listed buildings it's a
moot point
um that there are probably other
buildings nearer the listed building
which aren't listed
than the current one but i do absolutely
understand the rules regarding the
carthage and the barn
the other bond that's already there
being listed so i'll listen to what
others say but that's what i'm minded to
do at the moment
but i'm not at this stage making a full
proposal thank you councillor
muller you were next yeah thank you very
much chair yes having listened to
what um the applicant and the war member
that's present here say
i must admit i tend to sort of go along
with what council pass moore says on
this one
um again i would like to hear what
others say but at the moment i'm sort of
more in favor of it than against them
thank you
councilman yeah i i
i must say councilman
oh just just for clarity
i'm sitting at the back i can only
heckle from the back obviously
um uh yeah um
i am i i'm i'm a bit in two minds about
this i think
in a way it's odd that the the uh
the proposed settlement boundary change
between our uh our draft
uh submission and and the actual
submission um i am familiar with this
this particular village um uh the parish
council
are not supportive of the application
and neither is the other
ward member and i think although there
might be a bus stop
right outside the driveway or just down
the road outside manor farm it's one bus
a week
there are no pavements along ashfield
road norton
and there are some boggy footpaths
overgrown footpaths that you can get to
the church
but it isn't in my opinion a
particularly sustainable location
i hear um with the i hear what the
applicant's got to say
about it being a sustainable design and
a family home
um but and you know
it's it's one house and an okay
we've had reference to it being
affordable i'm well aware of the fact
that norton has very few
small affordable dwellings but this is
only really affordable for the family
who are living in it
it's not it's not a public benefit in
that sense
i presume because it's a family um
building the home
um it may not be may not contribute any
sill
so although i i i think on the face of
it
it's probably a a reasonable application
to try and put a house there
it is outside our proposed settlement
boundary
it isn't a particularly sustainable
location and i can't really see
what the benefits um to the commute to
the wider community
will be if this house is built so um
i'll hear what others have got to say um
before i
come to my final decision but it it it
really isn't
that sustainable um unfortunately
councillor field thank counselor
matheson
okay i find you know this is not an
isolated dwelling in the countryside
it's associated with a number of other
dwellings
so the fact that it's outside the
planning boundary is probably supported
by the mppf
on the heritage aspect we have a low
level of less than substantial harm so
it's
it's at the bottom end of that it is in
the area we can balance it against other
benefits
my feeling on sustainability which seems
to be the critical issue is that the
design is clearly sustainable
and it is a benefit to at least one
family
but there's the travel aspect is it
within walking or
cycling distance of facilities does it
insist that you use private cars
for transport and i suppose my feeling
is that
you know at one one and a half miles
from from
facilities it is within walking distance
i know i personally have a house which
is half a mile of the bus stop and
i can walk that and it's on a road
without a pavement
that's not the end of the world
so i feel the issue on transport is
perhaps
overemphasized that i personally accept
that this
is as sustainable a location as many
um and our fantasy to an extent about
using private cars if clearly they do
get used
we all use them i use one to get here
today
but that use is not just based on on
distance from the local shops it's based
on distance from an awful lot of things
and those distances are large even if
you live in the middle of ipswich
so um i think on that basis
i'll carry on listening but at the
moment i'm in favor of this
application in favor of
we've got the yeah we've got one more
speaker i'll speak who's had their hand
two more speakers then we'll probably
draw it to a conclusion council maths
yeah i
i think i i struggled to to want to
go against the wishes of of of both
um the the parish council which i'm very
keen on parish councils uh but also um
the officer um has assessed it as
as needing to be refused as well so
that's quite um quite difficult and yeah
i mean the bus service is
well it's derisively really i mean um
you can't have effectively used that i
agree with council field that
it is a walk it is a walk that one could
do and certainly it's a handy bike ride
to to the um the school the shop and so
on but
um i not enough to um
not enough to persuade me that the
the count the parish and the officer are
wrong
okay so
yeah um not a lot to add
the building is outside the settlement
boundary that for me
is is an issue um
if this were proved backfill we could
see other areas coming on the street
heritage i'd struggle to put too much
weight on that
given there are modern buildings closer
to the um
to the listed building than this one and
the fact that this proposal is for a low
build um you probably couldn't see it
from the listed building
sustainability i don't think we should
have
under emphasized the um the fact that
this enhances family life it enhances
one family's life and by doing so
it will cut the the transport
requirements
um and and that i think is is worth
considering
um it's easy bike ride to the center of
the village
um and can be walked but it is a
difficult one
um i still sit on the fence i'm afraid
i'm gonna have to make a decision
councilman can you get us off the fence
we're all in there
we're all we've got no proposals yet
uh no i'm not sure i can um chair um
yeah i mean it's an interesting one um
and i'm i find that the applicant and
the
ward members argument's quite persuasive
in terms of you know the
the benefits to family life and that
sort of thing there would be here
we do have that settlement boundary
coming in it's not in yet but um
you know when when the jlp has been
examined
it does sort of cut across just in front
of this
now there is obviously potential there
there's a long
some sort of x agricultural building it
would seem to me that
is going to sit within the boundary and
potentially
you could see that being a site for
development um
instead of this one i'm not quite sure
what the ownership is there
but clearly there is a long way from
facilities now having said that there is
other other development going along
on ashfield road you drive down there
and there's quite a few building plots
being built out at the moment
so we clearly have approved various
things along here
um but yeah the argument about
distance from facilities i find quite
persuasive
um but again you know it needs to be
balanced up with the other
issues which sort of recommend this site
okay well i'm anyone hasn't spoken so uh
i'll
try um so um
this is this is one of those
applications where um i've
i've flip-flopped massively so when i
read the papers i thought i couldn't
possibly support it surely but let's see
what the office is saying
now i've had all the information
presented i've i've sat
either side of the fence in the last 10
15 minutes but i have concluded
that i will support the recommendation
and the reason i'm going to do that
is because it is outside the settlement
boundary
and that then gives if we're wrong
if that is what members choose and
members may not
agree with me on this route then the
inspector
has that opportunity to be the person
who will determine
whether this is wrong or right and
obviously that's happened in
three other locations or two other
locations in the last two years
where actually on reflection the
inspector has come down in favor of the
applicant
for me to support this just sets that
difficult precedent of approving
development outside the settlement
boundary which we have always said for
many years
is sort of the go-to you know protection
that we put around now if this was a
granny annex for a family then it's a
whole different story but this isn't
this is a standalone
property that can be sold off in six
months time after it's
constructed could be i'm not obviously
we've heard the family story behind it
and that's not the intention
so for me i won't be supporting and i am
actually going to propose
refusal as per the recommendation and
see where we go it may get
you know we may have to go on come back
but that's what i'm going to propose
but i may not get a second one
so madison no i i i will
i will second that actually and and i
would just
remind members and and the chairs just
hinted at that of course
already that the the um the identity of
the applicant is
absolutely not a material consideration
and there's been quite a bit of emphasis
laid on that
by by the speakers before we we debated
um but i i had been reminded about that
over the years
in planning committees and um
along with along with the you know
any once you've got the principle of a
dwelling you've got a dwelling
you can't take it away again etcetera
you know those are the fundamentals that
we have to work with
and um so i will i will um
while accepting that there is a balance
here
i will support refusal
second it okay does anyone i mean should
we go to a vote on that and see where
that goes does anyone else want to speak
i think we've all spoken
let's go to the vote on that basis then
and see where it goes
if it comes back then someone else will
have to propose something different
thank you chair remembers your vote is
now in progress
thank you members chair that's six votes
for refusal and two against
okay members well thank you for today
um there's no
formally there's a formal bit to do
um okay do we have any site inspection
requests that need to be reported to the
committee
none received thank you very much okay
so i formally closed the meeting at 12
30. thank you everyone for joining us
you